do you guys know who the fitness
influencer Joe Aesthetics is yeah
apparently he just died
whoa yeah he is he was a 30 year old
German uh Fitness influencer massive
massive following
um Joe Linden correct yeah
um Noel daisell uh I think he's a South
African bodybuilder he's got a massive
following as well on on social media uh
just made a post about it but uh of
course the reason you know hasn't been
explained yet but uh could be Heavy use
of anabolics uh Hearts tied into that
maybe jabbed at some point
experimentally don't know but uh sad uh
for his family
um
yeah you gotta be careful out there guys
with your body it's one of those things
that can expire early and um
bodybuilding the bodybuilding Community
has a knack for erasing men early
earlier than they should be
there are a lot of organ issues with the
bodybuilding Community aren't there
yeah if you abuse
um here I'll grab the uh Instagram post
so you guys can see it uh but if you
abuse uh steroids it can have uh
you know negative effects this is him on
the right over here he's uh I think 182
centimeters and about 100 kilograms
um so not as not a small dude but not a
monster either uh Knoll here is a lot
bigger actually he's probably at least
40 or 50 pounds heavier but um yeah this
dude on the right that 30. boom
um it happens a lot in that in that
space in that Community uh quicker than
you know it
but uh rest in peace my man
um also the source of the
the juice is very important I have a bit
of uh anecdote here because I ordered
some stuff and got it from a new
supplier without the testosterone wasn't
actually testosterone it was trembolone
yeah nice yeah
did everything
massive Improvement in in strength yeah
since I usually go for low dose so I
thought I was doing testosterone I was
actually doing tremolon I noticed the
anger issues the Sleep the coughing
and I immediately immediately got off it
you know it takes about a week a week
and a half to flush out you gotta you
gotta be careful with underground lab
stuff man I I
um I don't know if I told you about our
story oh no it was what where firmware
it was from a factory in China
well that's pretty much the same thing
man because Trump alone is not
manufactured by pharmaceutical companies
for human consumption yep I'm here
you have recent convert just because uh
you're on a phone call there
um I was gonna say I I'm not sure if I
told you guys the story but there was
this gal that I dated in my 20s and uh
you know she was telling me how she used
to Homebrew Gear with her ex-boyfriend
in their basement and it was revealed
that they didn't actually produce
anything that was real they used to use
peanut oil and just put it in vials to
make it look like uh gear and sell it to
people so people were injecting peanut
oil in their ass uh and had absolutely
no anabolic properties whatsoever and
just imagine if you were allergic to
peanut oil or if you're allergic to
peanuts and you injected that
thinking you're taking gear yeah
Brazilian butt lift yeah you definitely
have a certain reaction to it could even
be worse than that but yeah I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel
Channel make sure you hit subscribe over
here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out